[Music]
thanks for joining us my name is Wyatt
Gorman I am a high-performance computing
specialist with Google cloud I'm based
in New York City
thanks for joining us at technical deep
dive into storage for high-performance
computing just quick show of hands how
many people know what high-performance
computing is what kind of workloads
there are and then keep them up and how
many people are actually users of HPC or
researchers or engineers or admins or
manage teams ok great about half
excellent
so we have please first of all if you
have any questions up front or
throughout the throughout the talk
please put them on our new Dory
it's a internal system that we've had
for a long time that's really helpful
for just submitting questions that you
might want to ask and easily going
through them so we have a great lineup
of speakers today again I'm Wyatt I have
with me Dean from Google cloud as well
as fan and men from data direct networks
and I'll let them tell you a little bit
about what they're doing with Google
cloud in the marketplace but first I
just want to talk about what HPC is for
those of you who don't know aren't
familiar with it so just some examples
of some industries that HPC users are in
that that really is fundamental to their
industry manufacturing so computer-aided
design chip design things like this life
sciences in terms of genomics financial
services climate modeling everything
like that right so as you might know for
those of you who do HPC in these
industries compute is the real driver
right so all the time questions are
getting bigger right demands for
computer growing and so we see this
especially in the top 500 supercomputers
so this is a graph of the growth of
those systems in flops which is
floating-point operations per second and
so you can see that we've grown now and
exceeded in total capacity an exaflop of
storage
performance I'm sorry and we're going to
see the first exascale system very
shortly around 2021
so all of this compute and also storage
is constantly growing so if you look at
the last ten years of storage growth we
started in 2008 with about three
petabytes on the largest system
roadrunner at Los Alamos that was about
fifty five gigabytes a second which was
pretty impressive for the time but in
just 10 years we've 83 axed the capacity
to 250 petabytes and a single storage
system and gone up to two and a half
terabytes a second which is absolutely
tremendous the the factors of scaling
that we're seeing not only in compute
but also in storage and so all of these
things together combining compute and
combining storage and software of course
drives your mission right it's not just
about infrastructure it's really about
your science and what you're trying to
do so a great example of that is the
Broad Institute the Broad Institute is a
genomics research organization and
genomic sequencing organization a
partnership with MIT and Harvard and
others and so these guys were able to
use in Google cloud and the massive
amount of compute that they have get the
price of processing a single genome down
to under $5 which is really tremendous
for making genome sequencing accessible
to the world and letting you do things
like 23andme and so on and so when you
think about what it takes to actually do
this work it really costs first of all a
lot of money so that's why you saw
National Laboratories owned these
systems to build these systems at a
massive scale is really a huge
undertaking not only in infrastructure
but also the hardware and you know
buildings and maintenance and everything
like that but it's also very difficult
to run these systems efficiently right
so you can see on the right a graph of
typical utilization in a system and blue
is the total capacity of your system
where the red is jobs and so at a time
of very high utilization you have users
sitting in the queue waiting for their
jobs to run waiting for other jobs to
complete and on the right you can see
times when there aren't enough jobs and
you're just wasting money running your
supercomputer
and so this is a problem even within
Google but we've gotten really really
good at bin packing which is a term used
in HPC which basically means just
utilizing your resources very
efficiently right
and so that's all driven by Borg and
we'll talk about a little bit about how
we do this in Google Cloud and so to
avoid having to deal with all of this on
your own system you know on Prem you can
really very easily turn to Google Cloud
for all of our very easy fast
provisioning our security and our
storage which we'll be talking about a
little bit more and so another user that
decided that it would probably be a good
idea to turn to Google was Twitter and
so you'll probably hear at our keynotes
this week that Twitter moved 300
petabytes of data to Google Cloud
storage and they used Google Cloud and
decided on Google cloud because of all
the reasons that I just showed you in
terms of faster provisioning flexibility
and security so in terms of
infrastructure and what it actually
takes to run HPC very quickly before we
dive deeper into the HPC storage you
really need three things
that's compute storage and networking
right so if we look at compute the
fundamental driver of compute and Google
Cloud is the Google compute engine and
so compute engine is really designed to
be powerful and flexible for your
workloads so we have up to four hundred
and sixteen CPUs in a single machine 12
terabytes of RAM would you just heard
about this week we have until obtain and
local SSDs which we'll talk about in a
little bit but we also have something
that's very key to HPC workloads called
custom machine types and so this is a
way that you can size your instance
choosing very specifically the number of
CPUs and RAM that you want to perfectly
fit every workload that you run on on
Google compute engine right so if you
have one one system that needs 12
terabytes of RAM and 400 cpus and gpus
right you can do that if you need one
that needs 12 CPUs and 12 gigabytes of
RAM you can build one we also have
computer optimized VMs which
our super high-speed CPU machines great
for HPC we have GPUs of course so we
have Nvidia K 80s all the way through T
fours as well as TP use which are
awesome for machine learning use cases
preemptable VMS are an awesome tool for
running check pointed and quickly
running code so they are up to 80% off
of a standard instance however they live
for a maximum of 24 hours and get can
get preempted any time within that 24
hours with 30 seconds of notice right so
again check pointed jobs jobs like
genomic sequencing where a single job
within a batch of jobs can fail and be
restarted is perfect for preemptable VMS
and then at the instance level
networking scales in terms of bandwidth
at 2 gigabits per second per V CPU up to
16 Giga bits per second per V CPU and we
support 15,000 vm's per VPC so that's a
lot of a lot of instances on a single
network if you need more than that let
me know and speaking of networking in
terms of the global network that you
need for massive collaboration and
massive data storage we have exactly
that so we've invested billions of
dollars into our network and when you
think about a global network you have to
think about laying undersea cables and
dealing with things like shark attacks
which sharks like the electromagnetic
signals coming off of the wires I don't
know why but so we have a shark proof
network it's just just one benefit and
then finally in terms of compute storage
we have a wide array of local compute
storage options in terms of not only
Google Cloud storage for object storage
but also persistent disk local storage
like local SSD and then file store and
and other solutions that we'll be
talking about just a little bit so to
talk about HPC storage in Google Cloud
at a larger scale I'd like to introduce
Dean
great thanks white
so what I wanted to talk a little bit
about is all right now we're thinking
about doing HPC in the cloud in many
cases you know users already have an HPC
infrastructure like a computer you know
Linux cluster or supercomputer or
something in their existing premise
they're not just coming to this you know
you're like brand-new but in a lot of
cases that that can happen too so what
you end up with is a series of
on-premise data centers each with their
own cluster and then connect it into a
variety of Google Cloud regions and so
the trick then is how do we get data
into the regions and back again and then
once we have the region up and running
how do we tailor make I like to say the
compute side and the storage side for
the workload that you're trying to run
so some of the common models that we're
seeing from a variety of HPC users
boils down into three categories one of
them is what I like to call launch which
is your running maybe MATLAB or some
smaller program on your laptop or on a
desktop somewhere and you're not using a
lot of compute because it's just a
single machine or a couple machines but
then you want to dynamically burst your
job into the cloud and so there are
partners that can enable that where you
know you're using two cores here let's
say and you burst out to you know 200
something and it becomes a very dynamic
real-time type bursting scenario good
for bursting compute not so good for
bursting storage because you know if
you're trying to do this in real time
you know you're gonna wait for that data
transfer to end up happening while
you're you're trying to dynamically
burst the the one that I see a little
more common is the burst by type I like
to say which is essentially taking the
workloads that are running on premise
and splitting them up into a set of
categories and so two categories might
be the HPC high performance type
workloads that you know require super
low latency networks and use MPI and a
variety of those kinds of tools and then
separating that out from the htc so the
high throughput computing which is more
you know embarrassingly parallel type
jobs or ensembles and in some
communities where they're running just
millions of smaller jobs on the system
and so what you can do is then you know
leave the the on-premise system that you
have optimized that for one set of jobs
let's say the HPC type jobs and then
burst the rest into the cloud and have
the data stored permanently up in the
cloud and so you're really sort of
bifurcating your data playing but as
well as your jobs and then that way that
enables you to optimize instead of
having to optimize on-premise for every
workload you know small I ops and and
Big Bend with jobs you can really
separate and target each one
individually and in the last one of
course is all in which is obviously you
know awesome and removes you know the
hassle of trying to do data movement
back and forth but you know I think that
that's more of a process right in terms
of getting there all the way to that
phase all right so on the storage side
then what you end up with is an
on-premise data center that probably has
your Linux cluster running and your own
storage system and then you have a set
of file systems that you might want to
target inside the cloud so here just as
an example have our Google Cloud file
store and then we have a lustre system
in the system and so first you can see
that we can tailor make the the compute
side of each of these clusters to
whatever the workload is right so file
store is a smaller you know NFS based
offering so you'd have a smaller set of
nodes that would be accessing that with
whatever you know number of CPUs that
they require and tailor making then the
storage and file store for whatever that
is whatever the requirements are and
then we have the other one as well on
the larger compute cluster that you're
going to have and then targeting a
lustre system that's optimized for
whatever the workload is right high
bandwidth high ops or whatever though
whatever is needed and then the
challenge becomes is how to get the data
back and forth right and so a lot of
cases you people are using cloud storage
in the middle for that data transfer
because it provides the secure and
highly bandwidth
pipe that you basically need in order to
get the data up you know and then from
cloud storage you can then essentially
burst out into your file systems and
then the results can then flow back the
other way as needed so talking a little
bit about our cloud storage offering I
think most of you might already know
about it but essentially it can be used
for a variety of different purposes you
can use it as your production you know
HPC storage offering or you can also
just use it as a coal tier right and
store essentially the cold data in your
system and save money by keeping it
there or you can just use it as again a
transitory place to copy data in and out
as as data is flowing back and forth
from your on-premise system and so cloud
storage is obviously awesome and it can
do amazing things and it can scale
across the globe but in many cases what
you end up with is still rakaat your
applications are not written for that
and if you're writing applications for
on-premise supercomputers or Linux
clusters you probably are not writing
applications for object storage in which
case you end up with needing file some
sort of file storage and so you know I
asked this question well what do you
mean file systems in the cloud like you
know we're gonna modernize write this
old file system stuff you know POSIX is
from you know 50 years ago like why are
we why are we there but the thing is is
many as I said in many HPC workflows
that are running today rely on a POSIX
based file system they rely on the
performance and they also rely on the
types of behaviors that file storage can
support such as in-place updates you
know handling large numbers of small
files because they deliver Layton sees
that are sub-millisecond versus you know
the much tens of milliseconds right that
object cloud storage provides so and the
other thing that I like to remind people
is that file is actually very cloud
friendly you know
NFS says the concept is built into Linux
and it's available from every VM that
you launch and it's a core part of the
kubernetes infrastructure and you can
dynamically use NFS
and kubernetes just without doing any
work whatsoever and so it's also very
friendly to preemptable VMS which is
another core part of HPC is as Wyatt
brought up and you know obviously very
familiar right all of us understand what
file is we do this on our laptops every
day these are the apps that you know we
were learning to write in university and
so you know it's just something that
becomes a very natural transition so
what I wanted to do then is go into some
of the details that ok so you're going
to use the cloud you're going to deploy
a larger file system inside the cloud
going through some of the just general
bare-bones ways on how GCP works in
terms of compute and storage so at the
top there we have our compute VMs and so
you know something you know as Wyatt
said you need to choose the right number
of e CPUs or if your GPUs or TP use
whatever the the infrastructure you need
for your compute layer but then these
nodes are also your file system client
right whether it's NFS or a POSIX based
clients such as lustre and so you need
to make sure that it has the bandwidth
that needs and so you add the two
gigabits per CC P you you always need to
make sure that you have enough of those
to at least deliver the the network
performance even if you didn't need them
you know you're gonna need them for the
network I'm sure so the next step then
is the storage servers so these file
system clients are then you know using
some level of distributed i/o across a
set of storage servers that you're gonna
launch right and these end up being VMs
inside of Google Cloud as well so you
need to keep the same things in mind the
one is the networking right there's no
point in putting up a whole bunch of
small VMs in many cases you're gonna
want to have the largest network
capacity possible so you're gonna want
to think about at least you know again
eight cores four for those servers and
you might then want to think about well
does it need does the file system
support some level of extra caching
where we could put in some local SSDs
how much ram do we want to support and
all of that can be configurable to
on the type of job the or that you're
using so then finally there's gonna be
some storage would be the point of the
file system and so you know if you're
gonna store this data durably you're
going to be using persistent disk and
then there's a few things that you need
to watch out there for as well and so
one of them is that the performance
scales linearly with capacity so you
know you can look at your capacity
requirements and then you have to look
at your performance requirements and
then you need to choose the capacity
vision the capacity that meets both of
those so you know some people don't like
paying for extra capacity if you're not
going to use it but don't think of it
that way right think about it is you're
paying for performance and you know some
of that is just logical right I mean if
you can't have the more capacity it has
the more spindles or the more SSDs
you're engaging which means then you
have you know enables more bandwidth
than I ops to the system right so that
it it works very similarly onto how
on-premise systems work the other thing
to remember is that with PD SSD there is
a set of V CPU requirements and that's
because the high IAP rates of using SSDs
just drives cores and so you it's a
tiered system but you get the best
performance with using 32 V CPUs at that
level and then the other thing is to
remember is that the scale linearly but
then they hit different limits at
different capacities and so it's easier
just to choose the largest capacity and
then you know you don't have to worry
about whether or not you could somehow
have eked out performance but some of
the common mistakes I've seen is where
they choose smaller VMs and smaller
capacities and then they have a lot of
them and it's just a lot easier to
shrink the number of VMs and storage
servers that you're deploying and
maximize out the bandwidth and the AI
ops of each of them
all right so we have a lot of storage
options in Google and it can be quite
confusing in terms of figuring out which
ones are you know right for you the top
row here is the structured storage
options which I always like to put up
but
you know we're focusing in on the bottom
ones today and so we talked a little bit
about cloud storage and persistent disk
and I'll mention file store briefly but
then we also have a set of HPC storage
partners that we're partnering with and
they're putting up different levels of
file systems inside of Google that are
really targeted towards these HPC use
cases so the first one to talk about is
Google's own file store so this is great
for small to medium sized jobs like I
said maybe a MATLAB job or some sort of
smaller and you know test system that
you're running and it's fully managed
and NFS based from from Google next if
you need to go bigger than that alas the
file is putting up a fully managed NFS
based scale load file system that really
is targeted as the next tier of file
store and delivers a really great number
of IAP so if you have a high IAP
workload then this is a great choice and
of course we have our net App Cloud
volume service and so with them you get
all the performance that you normally
expect out of using net upon premise but
you get it with all of the integration
and the ease of use of of GCP and so
it's just like the other two it's fully
integrated into the console and the
billing system and you could just
dynamically use it as if you were using
any of the other storage options in
Google and so we are also developing now
partnership with ddn around their luster
or service and their other software
storage offerings and so now I'm going
to pass it off to spend from ddn to talk
about that hello my name is Vinay I'm
the chief research officer for didi and
with me is Ming one of our senior
software developers let me switch to the
next slide so since this week we
actually announced on a marketplace and
you offering DDM acquired last year when
cloud which was influenced vision that
was running the last development
organization so ddn now essentially owns
the majority of all
developers worldwide so we brought a
service online min was instrumental and
actually get this up and running so and
while I'm speaking and talking over the
next slides I'm gonna pass it over to
min for a second he's gonna start a demo
to show you how easy it actually is to
deploy this on Google Cloud and while
the basically the deployment in the
background is running I'm gonna talk
about the rest of the slides thanks so
the lastest solution the easiest place
to fight is on the marketplace so we
just need to search for lustre okay and
here is our offering restaurant TCP and
as you see is similar to any other
offering so when we launch keep in mind
that this solution is long multiple
instances so you may want to plan ahead
of time so but we do provide
step-by-step and predefined profile for
you to just launch is the easiest so all
you need is a couple steps so the
deployment name is already prefilled if
you have one deploy already it will
change this deployment name to different
one the zone you can select your zone
and the network by default is just pick
whatever network does your zone in one
thing that you might want to consider is
using the private lustre network that
you choosing so for this demo I am just
a wrench and for the if you want to
access directly to your cluster from
outside you can just pick external IP
automatically allocate for you or you
can just you can select none and it will
create a rounder so that you can have a
gateway to jump into before you go into
your cluster file system name you can
change it
here is something that we have
predefined a couple profile to help you
know new user or user have different
level of needs so quixtar a pretty small
standard Standa plasm premium for today
demo I am going to just select a premium
and it also can be a capacity base where
its profile have a minimum requirement
for capacity so if you want to increase
more than that you just enter here and
step four if you don't select any
profile on step three you can go into
step four and make change to your server
any way you want some people they want
to you know tailor to the way that they
want to be a certain server certain
memory you can do all that customization
here the last step is select number of
client include into this deploy so for
our purpose I pick a client and I the
last step it just clicked the point and
the deployment approximately on this
deploy is about four minutes so while we
waiting for the deployment I will hand
that to back to seven and we'll come
back to here and when's it complete in
about four or five minutes and we'll
continue yeah thanks a lot min so a
couple of things to mention is probably
there is a default 8 by 5 support
associated with the service so you can
actually pick up the phone and call
somebody if there is a problem it is not
fully managed yet we looking for
feedback from customers if they also
want a fully managed service of that and
then we're gonna gonna look into this
and so if you deploy the system as means
that this is probably going to take
somewhere around 4 minutes we also
deployed large systems of you know
hundreds of terabytes in size and
everything is basically a matter of a
couple of minutes to get deployed so
it's actually is pretty easy and pretty
scalable if you need a very large amount
of capacity in
cloud so let's talk a little bit more
about luster and and what ddn is
actually bringing to the table here so
ddn's luster is is the number world
peril of fly system deployed we have a
large number of AI customers so we're
not just playing an HPC we have very
specific offerings in the H in the AI
space as well and the whole purpose of
Laster is really to provide very very
high performance where traditional files
having solutions typically lacking so
while it can do a lot of things with NFS
and SMB with normal workloads as soon as
you get to a massive amount of
parallelism they're typically not really
your choice of workloads so we have some
customers in today deployed in the world
if you look at like the top 500
supercomputers list massive amount of
them are actually running the lustre
file system inside so there is a very
interesting performance benchmark called
IO 500 I'm talking a little bit more
about that
and what you see here is essentially it
demonstrates the capabilities of that
offering so we have customers that have
millions of billions of files we can do
hundreds of gigabytes even terabytes per
second throughput with this technology
it's something that is really proven ly
deployed in many many sites so we
basically try to bring this on-prem
technology that we deploy in many many
sites today in the cloud to give
customers the choice to not just run
this on Prem but also get a very very
nice cloud experience with a very proven
technology that is deployed in many of
these areas today so the things that
primarily immuno differentiates lustre
from some of these other options that
you see on the marketplace is really
superiority and scalability as I just
said deploying hundreds of millions even
billions of files petabytes I systems we
have some systems on Prem today there
are three digits petabytes in size so we
know that the technology scaled so you
can deploy this in the cloud with the
same technology the other nice thing is
that you can very nicely scale it for
various types of workloads it doesn't
matter if you have massive random read
performance workloads or you have
massively sequential workloads for reads
or writes we have small files a large
files there is lots of options that you
can have we try to keep it as simple as
possible that's why we have
all these poor fights we can basically
pre-select from but if you need
something that is highly tailored for
your environment you can do this with
the offering as well and what a lot of
people don't know is many AI workloads
particularly and we really put lots of
effort in in this area rely on under the
cover on MF so many many libraries LM DB
and multiple others use MF under the
cover many other files store options
actually have significant performance
scaling issues with that and so we put
lots of investment into this area to
make this very very fast so we believe
that's why this option is is very
interesting particular if you try to run
AI workloads in the cloud because with
the distributed tries it and it has
optimizations for that a lot of the
frameworks that basically get shipped
out of the box on these systems gonna
run significantly faster if they
leverage a map under the cover we also
have you know given the size of the
deployments we already had there is lots
of expertise in the organization to
manage massively scalable systems we
actually run for lots of customers very
massively scaled systems on side so we
provide these extra services to
customers on Prem and basically with the
service offering and the knowledge that
we have in this area we try to bring all
of that into the cloud as well and we're
more than happy to also have separate
engagements in specialized services for
that if there are very specific needs
you have so the technology is is heavily
being worked on we try to tailor as I
said this offering specifically for
cloud there's lots of powerful tools
that we are in the process of launching
in subsequent releases that gonna come
over the next couple of quarters so you
have today already capabilities to set a
quota allocation in the system you can
either do this by subdirectory there is
options you can do this by user role by
group and we're gonna add significant
management capabilities in terms of
pooling so you have much more
fine-grained control as an end-user
or based on data that the system
automatically collects in terms of file
heat and being able to basically make
manage data placement across multiple
pools of different types of storage
inside the system at basically either
with the full automatisms and the tools
required for the end users to manage
that and we also have a
ability for doing very fast transfers
from on-prem to cloud because it's great
if you have an offering on the cloud or
if you have an offering on the prem but
if you can't figure out how to make the
movement for these very very large scale
systems working you need more than that
and we have a special product would you
have one extra slide for that and
there's auditing capabilities as well
that is required
obviously for lots of customers for
governments governance purposes and we
have lots of security features into this
solution as well so you can do things
like secure mounds where people only can
mount certain subdirectories of the
system without other people essentially
seeing the data of of each other so you
can basically separate each other's out
in in the file system namespace so IO
500 as I said there is a benchmark that
is used trying to provide basically a
very fair comparison between different
storage solutions in the market out
there we've done a couple of tests in in
the IO 500 benchmark with loud with with
Laster this is just one example of what
we deployed we basically deployed 120
client system 120 service system 180
terabyte capacity in total we achieved
hundred and seven gigabytes per second
throughput on the system and we
basically short absolute linear
scalability going from the smallest
configuration we've tested all the way
up and an S min already mentioned and
what we're going to show in the demo in
a few seconds is that all of this was
launched essentially and executed in a
couple of minutes this are the results
of the benchmarks so we did different
tests we scaled servers independently of
client so this is essentially the luster
server account scaling so you see the IO
500 score how it basically goes up when
we add servers after mention one point
the benchmark itself is very complicated
so as largely you make the benchmark
data size as more complex its execution
is and so it's higher you go basically
in the scores it tougher it's going to
be if you increase the scale of the
system and we also as I said in
increased the gigabytes per second
essentially but just adding individual
notes into the system so here you see
the scale basically going from ten
servers to 60 servers to 120 servers and
you see a basically a very nice scale of
that performance in the system and we
believe if you just add more nodes into
the system it's just basically gonna run
faster and faster as more resources you
add into this so the nice thing is as I
said you can scale capacity completely
independent from metadata and
independent of the IEEE ops or
throughput in the system so basically
whatever metrics you try to achieve it's
just basically a matter of picking the
right input for the deployment and we
can basically meet all of all of those
needs so two more slides that are very
specific I said this is our cloud
offering lots of our customers already
have on Prem offering or customers that
have a cloud offering also need an
on-prem offering so I want to show you
two slides of what we deployed today on
Prem so we just launched a new product
it's called SFA 18k it's essentially the
fastest storage controller for file
systems that you can purchase right now
it's essentially a for you device that
delivers ad gigabytes per second
throughput over the network and this is
essentially embedded running the same
master file system software that we
deploy on GC P so if you're looking for
an offering that needs to be deployed on
Prem this is a very very good offering
for that and the second slide that I
wanted to show you is a product called
dataflow so this is the one that
essentially ties this on-prem technology
with the cloud technology or also cloud
to cloud or also cloud or on-premise one
Prem so the products called dataflow and
what dataflow essentially does it
tightly integrates with multiple storage
sources and targets so it is not
actually limited to just lustre on Prem
and lustre on the cloud
it has targets to NFS it has targets to
SMB it has targets to IBM spectrum scale
file system it has targets to multiple
different sources and targets including
s3 and even has support for tape and
what differentiates this technology from
other simple file movement
data management solutions is that it's
particularly built for massive scale so
you can basically take a hundred
petabyte file system as a source and you
know a multi hundreds of terabytes or
petabytes right system in in the cloud
and you can basically fan out the data
movement across large number of nodes in
large number of networks so instead of
running on a single node it's
essentially gonna send a request to the
source system you specify with rules
what data you want to be moved it finds
the state are very fast with built-in
technologies in their technology if it's
supported so for example if you run this
against a spectrum scale cluster from
IBM it's going to use the policy engine
that is built in there it's going to
find the files very quickly that you
select then splits the workload across
large number of workloads and transfers
them in parallel into the cloud because
that's one of the big challenges with
just massive data movements how do you
move that data between cloud and
on-premise can't really do this from a
single node you need to massively you
know distributed system in order to do
that and basically a data flow is is is
providing you exactly that capability to
move between all these these different
technologies ok so there was the screen
last we left when it finished deploy
approximately for the 5 minute on this
particular profile so as you can see the
on the right hand side you see some
information what we provide is a web
console that you can see file you can
see your statistic or you can see status
of your list of our system so so this
will display the network the lustre
network file system name also the NID
the network owner and ID that you use if
you have new client bringing in to mouth
that is the mount point that you want to
use so all information is there and we
are running the latest version of lustre
2.12
0 and the center of 7.6
and below here is the information that
you can automatically we have automate
the way that we you can introduce new
cluster a new client into you know
mounting the same file system
so I read all that but one interesting I
want to show you is if you visit the
console you will see some a file system
lustre file system and you see metadata
and you see the the target the object
storage target that we just allocate and
the total file system just for this demo
I just launched 25 Parab terabyte with
using you know a few minute and the the
cluster here are showing the OSS which
is its server and we are using
approximately 10 OSS and the right hand
side are this read and write right now I
think is doing the read what I just did
what I launched an i/o our program on
client to demonstrate you know the this
activity so you can see as the DS is
reading at four hundred megabyte per
second right now and if we go to the
graph we including the ganglia graph you
can monitor this to stick a statistic
for last hour or day a week so you have
made a data server management server and
OSS so I'm going to show you the so we
have 10 OSS the first default screen is
going to be the low of OSS you can see
the low to spike up because we'll just
launched a IO our test one of the
interesting thing I mean you can see a
lot of statistic create write read for
individual OST if you want to look at it
but will
a total by read and write total on all
of them and they do a stack graph with
ten different color and you can see if
you click on individual one you can
actually see you know everything CPU low
luster let me see
we can collapse and we can look at the
OST matrix or the statistic is there for
you to to look and while you run your
application you can actually see the low
everything so I think that so as you can
see there's lots of detailed information
that we expose so it's very easy to also
find potential bottlenecks where you
might actually be limited by like if you
know exactly what the network limit is
of the individual instance you know that
when you deploy a larger system or
expanded what you basically have to pay
attention for min thanks a lot for the
demo I'm gonna hand it thanks man thanks
min so I think you know this is this is
where we want to get to right is is you
have your way you know there's the last
30 years has been optimizing how people
are doing an HPC on premise you know and
how they're deploying file systems and
you know ddn's the experts there and
compute servers and all these things it
in the cloud so we're trying to get to
well what's the best way to do it there
right and so we really want to change
some of the the general dynamics around
you know one massive file system that
you're just been packing all of your
workloads into and really sort of
thinking about how do we optimize the
entire workflow where you're expanding
the clusters when you need to you're
shrinking them down when they're not
needed you're targeting file systems
where you know you can set a set of jobs
for bandwidth better bandwidth optimized
and you can set a set of jobs that are
you know require high ops and really
targeting the
specific needs of the applications with
by you know doing the right
configuration within Google
[Music]